Новини дня «heute» з Барбарою Гальвеґ.
Доброго вечора та ласкаво просимо.
Про спорт розповість Норберт Леманн.
Найважливіші теми сьогодні:
Шокові події в США: щонайменше 19 дітей
загинуло під час стрілянини
у початковій школі Техасу.
Полегшення для мільйонів орендарів:
у майбутньому орендодавці також сплачуватимуть
кліматичний податок для житлових будинків.
Про Другу Бундеслігу: ФК «Кайзерслаутерн»
виграв матч проти ФК «Динамо Дрезден» за право
зіграти в Другій Бундеслізі та
здобув підвищення в класі.
Знову масове вбивство в одній з шкіл США.
Знову злочинець - підліток.
Новина про загибель 21 людини - 19 дітей
і двох вчителів - приголомшила увесь світ.
Поліція застрелила зловмисника.
Скорбота, біль і гнів в Ювальде,
невеликому містечку на південному заході Техасу.
18-річний підліток увірвався до школи й
почав стрілянину.
Усі постраждалі з одного класу.
Президент США заявив: «Як нація, ми маємо
запитати самі в себе, коли заради Бога ми
виступимо проти збройного лобі?».
З США Елмар Тевессен.
Вони втратили найцінніше - cвоїх дітей.
Серед них Хав'єр Лопес, 10 років,
дуже життєрадісний, каже його родина.
Саме опівдні
стрілець руйнує життя і надії.
З напівавтоматичною зброєю він вривається до
початкової школи, вбиває 19 дівчаток
та хлопчиків і 2 дорослих,
вражає людей з маленького містечка
в саме серце.
В Ювальде проживає 15 000 людей.
Поліціянтам вдалося застрелити
18-річного Сальвадора Рамоса після перестрілки.
Він виріс у проблемній родині, часто зазнавав
знущань, а зовсім нещодавно легко зміг
придбати зброю на свій день народження.
Президент США Байден, помітно вражений,
сповнений рішучості ще раз переглянути закони
про зброю.
Коли заради Бога ми нарешті виступимо проти
збройного лобі?
Прапори приспущено,
але республіканці в Конгресі
відмовляють у підтримці.
Ви вже бачите, що демократи й багато
представників ЗМІ хочуть обмежити
конституційне право законослухняних громадян.
Благаю вас, мої колеги.
Навіщо ви намагаєтесь потрапити
до Сенату США, якщо вашою єдиною відповіддю
на масову загибель людей, дітей, що
тікають від смерті,
якщо вашою єдиною відповіддю є бездіяльність?
Ірма, Хав’єр, Амері, Ева, Узія, Аннабель
та багато інших.
США - це єдина країна в світі,
у якій вбивці можуть
так легко руйнувати життя та надії.
Елмар Тевессен у Вашингтоні.
Чи посприяє це велика кількість жертв тому,
що зараз щось зміниться?
Я так не думаю.
Це нагадує випадок Сенді-Хук у Коннектикуті.
Майже десять років тому.
Тоді загинуло 26 осіб.
Тоді лунало багато обіцянок.
Після цього нічого не відбулося,
крім того, що відбулося ще 3500 масових вбивств -
перестрілок, під час яких загинуло більше
ніж чотири людини.
Не було жодного посилення законів про зброю.
Через відсутність більшості щодо цього.
Для ухвалення такого рішення потрібно принаймні
десять сенаторів-республіканців.
Така перспектива не є ймовірною.
Демократи розраховують на зміну більшості.
Вибори до Конгресу відбудуться у листопаді.
Навряд чи необхідна більшість буде досягнена,
оскільки
для багатьох американців це питання не є
найважливішим.
Про боротьбу за закони про зброю детальніше в
ZDFheutelive о 19.30 з Ельмаром Тевессеном,
на каналах в соцмережах і в додатку ZDFheute.
Саме там можна знайти наші підсумки щодо того,
що президент Байден хоче й може зробити,
щоб приборкати збройне насильство.
Про війну в Україні: позиції українського
фронту починають коливатися.
За останні декілька днів російські війська
масовими атаками витіснили українські
війська з декількох населених пунктів
на cході країни.
Володимир Зеленський стверджує, що потрібно
буде докласти чималих зусиль,
щоб подолати перевагу Росії в озброєнні та
технічному оснащенні.
Детальніше Фолькер Дучек.
Місто, понівечене трьома місяцями війни -
Сєвєродонецьк на сході України.
Під постійним обстрілом відтоді, коли Москва
стягнула сюди свої війська.
Не багато цілей було
під таким інтенсивним обстрілом.
Лише сьогодні шестеро загиблих і вісім поранених.
Сєвєродонецьк є стратегічно важливим через
транспортне сполучення та розташування.
Мета: з підкореним містом в тилу
Москва змогла б атакувати інші регіони України.
Те саме стосується міста-побратима Лисичанська.
Тепер росіяни намагаються оточити обидва міста
з трьох боків.
Російська армія, очевидно, змінила свою стратегію.
Принаймні, такої думки дотримуються військові
експерти США.
Москва наразі відмовилася від планів
широкомасштабного оточення
Збройних Сил України.
Натомість вона намагається виснажити,
оточити та розбити малі групи українських військ.
Володимир Зеленський переконаний, що
Сєвєродонецьк буде зруйновано
й одразу називає інші цілі,
яким загрожує така сама доля.
Наприклад: Лиман, Попасна, Слов'янськ.
Майже 40 міст та населених пунктів на Донбасі
перебувають під обстрілом.
Державне телебачення показує Путіна,
що відвідує постраждалих у лікарні.
На вигляд нетравмовані солдати
розмовляють зі своїм президентом.
Посил цього вчинку може бути таким:
Вступайте до армії - тут ми піклуємось
про поранених.
Йоганнес Гано в Одесі.
Що Ви можете розповісти про військову ситуацію?
Атаки на Донбасі є особливо важкими.
Сьогодні по всій країні було завдано масових
ракетних ударів.
Було зруйновано декілька заводів.
Сьогодні о 4:30 нас було вирвано зі сну.
Українська армія повідомила, що
російська армія укомплектувала підводні човни та
кораблі, що неподалік від берега, ракетами.
Очікуються, отже, сильні ракетні удари з моря.
Нас попередили, що в південному регіоні
можуть літати бомбардувальники.
Cьогодні ми відвідали
фермерів на південному фронті.
Там завжди чутно звуки артилерії.
На півдні країни тривають масивні бої.
Російські війська намагалися вночі
здійснити прорив.
Вони перевдяглися в форму українських військових, але
але зазнали поразки.
Мер міста і його прес-секретар розповіли нам,
що очікується спроба
росіян захопити місто Миколаїв, проте наразі
їм бракує військ для цього.
Війна спричиняє великі втрати
серед особового складу обох сторін.
Напевно, тому російський парламент поспіхом
скасував чинне вікове обмеження для
професійних військових.
Досі служити в армії могли лише ті росіяни,
чий вік не перевищував 40 років.
В Україні війна є повсюдно,
навіть далеко від фронту.
Сирени попереджають про повітряні атаки.
Потрібно піклуватися про солдатів, але й також про
нових біженців, кількість яких зростає.
Наш репортер Геннер Гебестрайт з’ясував
ситуацію в Дніпрі.
Четверте за величиною місто країни розташоване
приблизно за 100 кілометрів від фронту.
Становище в пункті прийому біженців
при православній церкві
чітко відображає ситуацію на Донбасі.
Дедалі більше людей прибувають до найбільших
пунктів прийому такого типу
в Україні: за добу тут можуть допомогти
2500 людям, яких війна вигнала з їхніх домівок.
Я зараз у Дніпрі, бо тут набагато спокійніше
і безпечніше, а нашим дітям більше не
треба боятися.
Звичайно, що найближчим часом
я не повернуся додому.
Це підвищує тиск на місто з 900 000 мешканцями.
Наразі в Дніпрі офіційно зареєстровано
90 тис. біженців.
Міський голова Філатов припускає, що
насправді їх вдвічі більше,
а надалі їхня кількість стане ще більшою.
Наразі на Донбасі бої постійно загострюються.
Тому там постійно проводяться масові евакуації.
Майже дві третини біженців спочатку
прибувають сюди.
Ми прийняли найбільшу кількість
біженців після Львову.
Забезпечити біженців продуктами, ліками та
предметами гігієни стає дедалі складніше.
Переселенці можуть отримувати допомогу
раз у три тижні.
Але гуманітарна допомога із Західної Європи
дедалі частіше затримується в дорозі.
Нашою основною проблемою є брак продуктів,
що довго зберігаються.
А оскільки в Україні закінчується паливо,
то стає дедалі складніше постачати гуманітарні
вантажі від західного кордону до Дніпра.
Уже зараз вони потребують 20 тонн гуманітарного
вантажу раз на чотири дні,
щоб змогти забезпечити батьків та їхніх дітей
найнеобхіднішим.
Переведімо годинник назад:
розпал пандемії в Лондоні,
приватні зустрічі заборонено,
прем'єрміністр Борис Джонсон закликає до
розсудливості й дисципліни.
Жодних вечірок.
Якщо тільки ви не працюєте на Даунінг-стріт, 10.
Там відбуваються святкування.
У звіті щодо розслідування,
який було оприлюднено сьогодні,
йдеться про те, як часто й наскільки регулярно.
Соромно, але це не є причиною для відставки,
стверджує Джонсон.
Діана Ціммерман.
Тепер Борис Джонсон може почитати 37 сторінки
про те, що відбувалося в його уряді
під час локдауну.
Було оприлюднено звіт про вечірки,
що засвідчує надмірне вживання алкоголю
під час щонайменше 16 вечірок, порушення правил,
невдале лідерство й грубе
порушення очікуваних стандартів.
У звіті наголошено, що політичне керівництво
на Даунінг-стріт має взяти на себе
відповідальність. І я роблю це.
Я покірно стою перед вами й запевняю, що
я засвоїв урок.
Серед іншого Джонсон засвоїв і те, що
13 листопада 2020 року він дійсно був присутнім
на вечірці на Даунінг-стріт,
хоча він і заперечував це в парламенті.
Але фото з вечірки з’явилися лише позавчора.
Анонімний свідок зауважила, що на цих кадрах
зображена типова поведінка прем'єрміністра.
Він ніколи не казав:
«Розійдіться, будь ласка, по домівках,
тримайте дистанцію, вдягніть маски».
Він навпаки зазвичай наливав і собі келих.
Опозиція обурена.
У звіті описане те гниття,
що заповнює резиденцію уряду
під час правління цього прем'єрміністра.
Він власноруч доказує,
наскільки зневажливо люди в цій будівлі
ставляться до жертв,
які принесли британців під час пандемії.
Проте прем'єрміністр не бажає
добровільно йти у відставку.
І час грає на його стороні.
Завтра починаються канікули у парламенті.
Борис Джонсон сподівається,
що після святкування ювілею королеви,
депутати охолонуть і будуть неохочі
пред'являти йому вотум недовіри.
Нове рішення федерального уряду
має полегшити фінансовий тиск
на мільйони орендарів.
Йдеться про кліматичний податок
на викиди вуглекислого газу.
До сьогодні орендарі сплачували податок самостійно.
В майбутньому частина до сплати,
а саме від 0 до 90 %,
припадатиме на орендодавця.
Чим енергоефективніший будинок,
тим менше сплачуватиме орендодавець.
Репортаж Бернда Бентіна.
Кожен, хто опалює житло нафтою чи газом,
сплачує податок на викиди CO2.
Залежно від квартири чи будинку,
сума може перевищувати 100 євро на рік.
Уряд хоче частково зменшити
фінансовий тиск на орендарів.
Наразі орендарі повинні самостійно
сплачувати податок на викиди.
Проте це не відповідає початковій меті цього податку.
Податок повинен заохочувати
зменшувати кількість викидів СО2
шляхом переобладнання будівель
на більш екологічні.
З цією метою була розроблена 10-етапна модель.
Орендарі будівель з низьким рівнем викидів
продовжуватимуть платити податок самостійно.
Однак чим гірше стан будівлі з погляду екології
і чим вище рівень викидів, тим більше
повинен сплачувати орендодавець -
до 90%.
Захисники прав споживачів висловлюють критику,
що у будь-якому разі 10% залишаться
до сплати для орендарів.
Ця 10-етапна модель складена на користь орендодавців,
а не орендарів.
Тобто врешті орендарі все одно
сплачуватимуть більше, ніж орендодавці.
Ми вважаємо це несправедливим.
Орендодавці ж скаржаться,
що нововведення не дасть імпульс
до позитивних змін,
а лише заблокує інвестиції.
Модернізація будинків з метою
підвищення їхньої енергоефективності
у наступні роки й десятиліття коштуватиме мільярди.
Тому важливо, аби власники
були здатні інвестувати в це.
Це означає,
що гроші, які отримуватиме держава як податок,
не підуть на інвестиції й будуть втрачені.
Урядова коаліція вважає нововведення
справедливим розподілом фінансового тиску
й обіцяє прозору й необтяжливу бюрократію.
Закон набуде чинності в січні 2023 року.
У Шлезвіґ-Гольштейні CDU і партія Зелених
розпочали сьогодні у другій половині дня
коаліційні перемовини.
Раніше розмови про перемовини, після Зелених,
підтвердив також і Союз.
Обидві партії планують
розробити коаліційний договір
протягом наступних трьох тижнів.
Багатодітні родини отримають пільги,
а саме завдяки змінам
у внесках на страхування на догляд.
Таке рішення ухвалив сьогодні
Федеральний конституційний суд.
Отже, батьки платять менший внесок,
ніж дорослі, що не мають дітей.
Проте батьки з двома і більше дітьми
мають вищі витрати на виховання,
через що опиняються в невигідному становищі.
Позивачі також сподівалися на зменшення внесків
на пенсійне й медичне страхування.
Проте суд постановив, що у цьому нема потреби.
Кому ще потрібна церква?
До цієї теми привертають увагу на З'їзді католиків,
який сьогодні починається у Штутґарті.
Там віряни борються, наприклад,
зі ставленням їхньої церкви до
жінок у священстві,
до гомосексуальності
або гендерної ідентичності.
Крім того, вони борються проти кризи довіри,
яка загострилася внаслідок скандалів навколо
розбещення у католицьких церквах.
За попередні роки рекордна кількість католиків
перестала підтримувати свою церкву.
Репортаж Еви Шиллер.
Він є маленькою сенсацією для католицької церкви.
Хоча Тео транссексуал,
єпархія зробила для нього виняток,
дозволивши йому викладати релігію.
Надя вивчає теологію
і все одно має сумніви по дорозі до З'їзду католиків:
Надто мало охочих прийняти сан священника,
занадто мало душпастерських референтів.
У такому стані, в якому на цю мить перебуває
католицька церква,
вона не зможе надалі існувати.
Цю проблему часто характеризують так:
«Того, що вони проповідують в неділю,
вони не дотримуються з понеділка до суботи».
Віряни запитують себе, навіщо вони тоді
залишаються в такій церкві.
Ці коливання між гнівом і надією
об'єднує багатьох на 102-у З'їзді католиків.
Очікується 30 000 відвідувачів -
це вдвічі менше від минулого разу.
На відкритті федеральний президент закликає
до припинення війни в Україні й до змін.
Важливим є те, що розбещення, затаювання й
затяжне розслідування
зашкодили довірі й навіть знищили її
у багатьох людях.
Водночас це також підірвало
впевненість церкви в собі.
Масові виходи з церкви стимулювали її
розглянути різні питання на З'їзді католиків,
а саме теми насильства, сексуального різноманіття,
більшого залучення жінок на церковні посади.
Наразі церква у кризовому стані.
Ми це розуміємо.
На мою думку, тим важливіше є
подолання цієї кризи.
Цього можна досягнути лише разом, шляхом
дискусій на цьогорічному З'їзді католиків.
Проблема полягає в тому,
що на цьому дні не присутня більшість
консервативних членів церкви.
Тео запитує себе,
наскільки ефективним будуть
заклики молодих католиків до реформ у церкві,
якщо справжня дискусія не видається можливою.
Марго Фрідлендер, яка пережила Голокост,
отримала відзнаку за її активність у нагадуванні
про звірства нацистського режиму.
Вільний університет Берліна нагородив її
науковим ступенем почесного доктора наук.
100-річна Марго Фрідлендер каже,
що її місія, яка полягає в тому,
аби ділитися своєю історією,
стала для неї справою життя.
Для вас, для майбутнього, для демократії -
залишайтеся людьми.
До неї завжди варто дослухатися.
Передаю слово Норберту, який розкаже
новини Відкритого чемпіонату Франції з тенісу.
Андреа Петкович вилетіла з другого туру.
Однак німецькій тенісистці №1 Анжеліці Кербер
вдалося вийти у третій тур.
Олімпійський чемпіон Алєксандр Звєрєв
переміг аргентинця Себастіана Баеса
у напруженому матчі з п'яти сетів.
Перші два сети здається, що Звєрєва зурочили,
навіть вітер проти нього.
Його 21-річний суперник,
над яким він нещодавно в Римі здобув перемогу,
ганяв його по всьому корту,
наче йому, Себастіану Баесу,
доля вже прирекла перемогу.
Він незчувся, як програв сет з рахунком 2:6,
а потім і другий з рахунком 4:6.
Перспектива вилетіти зі змагання
пробудила бойовий дух Звєрєва.
Перемога у третьому й четвертому сетах
дістається йому.
Тепер він має перевагу у матчі,
в якому до цього програвав.
Коли рахунок у шостому геймі зрівнюється,
Звєрєв, не втрачаючи запалу, здобуває гору.
Сет закінчується із рахунком 7:5.
Матч, що тривав понад три з половиною години,
був великою боротьбою з сильним противником
і з власною витримкою.
У вівторок увечері «Кайзерлаутерн»
перемогли «Динамо Дрезден»
у перехідному матчі-відповіді
з рахунком 2:0.
Після чотирьох років у Третій лізі
«Кайзерлаутерн» повернувся в Другу.
Саксонці ж, навпаки, вчетверте в історії клубу
вилетіли у Третю лігу.
Цього разу ФК «Кайзерслаутерн» забив важливі голи,
на нього чекає новий початок.
Нарешті вони знову у Другій лізі.
Непересічно якісна гра.
Я неймовірно радий
і пишаюся командою
за її досягнення у цьому році.
На 59-й хвилині завдяки першому голу
від Данеля Гансліка
«Кайзерслаутерн» отримує перевагу.
У «Динамо Дрезден» були шанси
на перемогу в цій грі.
Однак у додатковому часі Філіп Герхер
забив другий гол.
Рахунок 2:0 перетворив мрію команди
про Другу лігу на реальність.
Гра закінчилася піротехнічним божевіллям
від вболівальників «Динамо Дрезден»:
вогонь, петарди, переривання гри.
Опісля ж «Кайзерслаутерн» могли святкувати
перемогу й повернення в Другу лігу.
Вони дійсно заслужили своє місце -
вітання клубу «Кайзерслаутерн».
А зараз лотерея:
виграшні номери: 1, 5, 15, 28, 32, 45.
Суперномер: 5.
Інші виграшні номери можна знайти на lotto.zdf.de
або в ZDFtext на сторінці 557.
Завтрашнього святкового дня
насолоджуватимемося прохолодною
й сухою травневою погодою.
Де очікуються зливи, розкаже Катя Горнеффер.
О 21:45 Марієтта Сломка з «heute journal».
Будемо раді вам завтра.
Дякуємо за перегляд і бажаємо гарного вечора.
До побачення!
Добрий вечір,
цього травня у багатьох регіонах засухо,
проте місяць ще не закінчився.
Погода порадувала дощами у Баден-Вюртемберзі,
у Баварії, а також у Саксонії.
У другій половині дня опади перемістилися
на північ і продовжили свій рух далі.
Також місцями були грози.
На цей час погода залишається мінливою,
стане прохолодніше.
Сьогодні вночі температура знизиться
і коливатиметься між 13° і 7°.
На узбережжях Північного й
Балтійського морів дощитиме.
На півдні буде місцями ясно.
Завтра через Північну Німеччину пройдуть дощі.
Проте в перервах частіше буде сонячно.
Віятиме західний вітер.
Далі на південь буде все сонячніше.
Найбільше сонячного проміння буде завтра
між районами Берхтесґарденер й Алльґой.
Сонячність - не єдина відмінність між
півднем і північчю.
Ще однією є температура.
Найтепліше буде завтра на Верхньому Рейні - 32°.
На узбережжях Північного й Балтійського морів
температура буде нижчою, а саме 16°-17°.
У наступні кілька днів холодне повітря
пройде всією Німеччиною.
У неділю температура буде лише у межах 12°-19°.
У наступні дні особливо на північному сході
будуть зливи й грози. Гарного вечора!